[Music]
you ready
absolutely come on let's get started
welcome back he's going to say who
welcome
that'll make you want to slap your mama
right there boyd
[Music]
what do these do hang grenades
it's very american yeah it is rated r
if someone wanted to take out kingsley
they've got to be planning something
major
some kind of underworld organization the
golden circle
say goodbye to the kingsman what a bit
if a say the world situation
here and follow the doomsday protocol
let's get started
that'll make you want to slap your mama
kingsman the golden circle rated off
september 22nd
we're from the kingsman taylor shop in
london
maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
but
i'm going to show you say goodbye
to the kingsmen
kind of got a bit of a save the world
situation here
welcome to statesman as your american
cousins
we'll be working side by side let's get
started
we've got brains skills
skipping rope
[Music]
it's a lasso whatever
[Music]
it's very american yeah it is
manners make it amazing
do you know what that means
[Music]
you